bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got
michael here thank you so much for
joining me sir
thanks thanks for having me absolutely
let's just jump right into your
background before we talk about fire
blocks but uh you know where did you
grow up and what did you do before
firefox
yeah sure so uh grew up in israel
uh and i guess uh
fairly i guess fairly typical for an
israeli entrepreneur actually spend the
the first two decades of my career in
cyber security actually
started there in that domain when i had
to do my mandatory service in the
israeli army so i was working for the
israeli cyber command about
you know 20 years ago as part of our my
uh
military duty over there and about 10
years ago i started my previous startup
that was focused on
mobile cyber security so if you guys
remember the days where people were
buying iphones and android devices and
they would come to work and ask the
it to connect those devices to the
to the network or you know to get emails
and documents something is like
completely trivial today uh when that
happened about 11 years ago
uh the it guys will get a heart attack
and we'll freak out
uh so we build the first platform to
basically secure those devices from
cyber attacks and you know work with uh
with a lot of the fortune 500 companies
and about four years into that venture
we got acquired by a company called
checkpoint that
is one of the biggest cyber security
vendors and i was running their mobile
and cloud security
portfolio so basically their
transformational unit that
was supposed to take them from from
traditional iit infrastructure
into you know modern age um so i've been
there for three years
and then basically there was something
quite interesting that happened in 2017
that
basically drove us into into crypto into
this uh
super exciting world of uh you know the
new finance
what was that interesting thing so uh
early in 2017 there was a hack in south
korea that basically 200 million dollars
worth of bitcoin uh
disappeared in from four exchanges in
south korea and reappeared in north
korea
uh and so there was a pretty significant
hack over there
and part of that hack was actually done
through mobile devices because we had
the the best team in the world in terms
of doing investigations around the
mobile forensics we we assisted that
investigation
and you know i've seen a lot of bad
things happen to many people or many
organizations through my career
but you rarely see people lose 200
million dollars over
overnight and so that was you know
really eye-opening for me and
i basically went down the rabbit hole
and and started to
talk with a lot of the financial well
you know financial institutions or
you know crypto fintech companies that
were operating in the space to
understand
what are the gaps they have why why that
happened you know and sort of
understood the lack of infrastructure i
guess that uh
we had back in 2017 2018 which really
attributed to a lot of those hacks and
and to the
all the crypto that was lost uh in the
last
decade and so that's basically what
happened and i think it was
you know really what drive us to into
the space to
to come and you know what to fix a
problem that initially
i think we saw we thought it's just a
bit you know
very fundamental operational security or
cyber security problem
but eventually what we discovered is
that we are much more of a fit the
company
that is basically building the builds
the the plumbing you know for uh
for how crypto can can flow absolutely
and so if we kind of talk through fire
blocks uh maybe walk us through
the evolution of the business right so
kind of what was the original idea
and then kind of how has it grown over
time with the product suite and number
of things that you
you offer to customers today yeah so
interestingly enough i guess the product
or the fundamental idea
didn't change much much since we're
basically you know contemplating what
we're trying to solve so
the idea started from a fairly simple
observation that
there was lack of i would say secure hot
wallets that are
um suitable for institutional usage so
that was a
problem number one and problem number
two that we recognize is that
actually the problem is not always with
the storage or with the walls themselves
is actually how do you
meet or how do you send the payment
because it was very evident that when
you're sending a big transaction
when you copy paste the address you
basically they're like
five seconds where you get a heart
attack right that you don't actually
know if the crypto i think like when you
press refresh on the block explorer to
see if it's actually going to be
to the address on the other side um and
you know some of the first customers we
started to work with were genesis and
galaxy and saw those big otcs that were
doing
hundreds of transactions per day and it
was very clear that this is
a huge problem for them and i guess you
know when we
thought about how the space is going to
evolve you know i think we had in our
mind something that looks like
how it looks today right there is big
big money flowing around that you know
left and right and
and at scale and this need to be solved
so we basically
created a very secure uh hot wallet
offering which we call the firebox vault
that is based on multi-party computation
with hardware security and the second
part which
we are i guess most famous for is the
firebox network that is basically
serving like this um institutional
authentication layer
basically the swift for crypto for
institutions to
make sure that they authenticate each
other from an address standpoint
that was you know how we started you
know with time i think it evolved to
a much more comprehensive offering which
is almost like
a crypto backend as a service um so any
financial institutions where is that you
know hedge fund or otc desk or
market maker or payment provider or bank
or exchange they need to basically set
up like a full stack of services that
goes from a wallet to settlements to
compliance
to um you know reconciliation and then
to the more advanced use cases like defy
and and staking
and now fire blocks is basically you
know more or less that
you know i think everybody would like to
to give this comparison but a bit like
the aws
for if you need to do crypto basically a
platform where you can activate
different components
uh and start from sometimes from
something that is very basic
but then just like activate more and
more components and essentially
take advantage and you know sort of uh
bootstrap your business into then like
in a full speed where you do
everything possible in crypto absolutely
so one of the things i want to talk
about
uh today is just like the comparison
between the legacy
financial infrastructure and then what
you're building with fireblocks and kind
of digital asset infrastructure
some of it is similar and there's a lot
of comparisons and then some of it is
very very different
and obviously you and i believe that
some of those differences are
advantageous
uh compared to the legacy system so
maybe what we could start with is just
the similarities right so when you look
at the legacy system
and the digital asset system
specifically what you're doing with fire
blocks what are the similarities between
those two systems
yeah so i think that to a certain extent
there will be similarities in terms of
the participants
in the market right i think that um
many years ago people would say you know
a few years ago that
maybe there was like a notion that
crypto is going to disintermediate
everything
i think that we realize more and more
that
the players that own the end user
are probably going to stay right so you
will have
um neo banks and banks and payment
providers that will still basically
hold the end the customer relationship
and they would
you know basically provide some kind of
wallet services or account services
i think that this is pretty much uh you
know i i don't think that
eventually it will be that or for the
next
for the foreseeable future i don't think
that um the entire
world population will work with ledger
nanos in their pocket
you know unfortunately i guess um so i
think that that part of the market's
infrastructure will
will will survive and then um
you also have the market makers that
need to basically supply liquidity to
you know to interact with the different
protocols so i think that
so the perimeter of the of the
environment is
is going to be pretty much the same
um what's definitely going or i hope
like you know that
what's going to basically be changed is
i think two things
one is the counterparty risk and the
transparency
that people have into actually what's
going on behind the scenes
and and the second aspect is sort of um
some level
of disintermediation or you know
flattening of the pyramid of of trust
that exists
you know inside of the ecosystem when it
comes to
just having you know today there are
just too many layers that
um you know eventually constitute a lot
of
eventually a lot of risk right a lot of
dependencies that on normal days they
work
fine you know but on a bad day when the
market is stretched
they break right then when they break
there is sort of this ripple effect that
goes through the market and eventually
by the way
um it propagates to the end user to the
end customer
absolutely and let's talk a little bit
about the the big differences right so
obviously uh similarities
are uh are uh clear and they're great
jumper typically those where the major
difference is
why do you feel like the digital assets
uh and fire block system is superior or
advantageous compared to
uh kind of legacy system yeah so i think
that there are basically two
um you know the base layer i think there
are two
components that should be significantly
rethought right the first one is
what is really the concept of custody
right of or
account management in in some ways and
the second concept
is basically um you know around
the settlement or the clearing layer
basically how do you connect or how do
you move the assets between uh
in the marketplace um you know so so for
the first part
um you know we were very
i guess you know we developed probably
or we progressed a lot the
utilization of um this idea of using mpc
basically multi-party computation for
for wallet protection but beyond
the math that goes beyond goes around
and beyond the security
actually one of the most the advantages
uh aspects of
mpc is that you sort of remove the
counterparty risk and
and a single point of failure and the
um trust that you actually need to to
put
in the party that is servicing you so
that party can still be
your you know back-end they can still
enforce some of the policies but at the
end of the day
from a sort of like you know a final
operation risk so for example our
customers
if fire blocks goes down and disappears
tomorrow morning
their crypto is safe there is a way for
them to recover it right
whereas if you look at other custodial
models
and that is actually not the case and it
also like you know forces us to
basically operate in a very different
way right so
all the accounts are segregated right we
don't commingle
things uh and and uh
at the end of the day what people see in
our ui is also what people see in their
address on the blockchain right and
those things are actually
fundamentally different from the way
that the traditional
system works where you will have um
you know an account in a bank is just
like a a top pledger that represents
something that you actually don't have
any idea what's going on
behind it right it can be full reserve
it could be partial reserve it could be
like
a 10 percent reserve it can be you know
invested in a lot of different things
but eventually you don't have any idea
what it actually represents beyond you
know what you see in the ui
so that's that's i think like you know
component number one
uh i hope it makes sense no no it makes
complete sense
and so like i want to talk about certain
aspects of the crypto industry
um and i figured i can kind of just
throw a topic out there and then you can
give me an update in terms of what are
you doing at fire blocks and then kind
of how do you think about the overall
kind of sub-sector if you will uh and
maybe the place that we could start uh
we are recording this on the day that
bny
mellon is announcing all of their
custody and kind of the
oldest bank in america and they're
talking about everything from
bitcoin cryptocurrencies and digital
assets one of those
uh i likely think will be stable coins
how do you think about stable coins for
your business and then how do you think
of it from a kind of industry sector
that seems to be getting a lot of
attention from legacy world
yeah so i think that actually also
relates to the second part of the
question of how why it's different than
why people are excited about stablecoin
so i think that
um at the end of the day one of the
really fascinating things here
is how stable coins are going to
disseminate
intermediate people like you know visa
right in my
opinion right and i think this is some
of the reasons why
you see visa and mastercard sort of like
you know rushing to
figure it out because and i'll just tell
you like
our personal story um so we accept
we accept payments from our customer
it's basically a monthly license or a
quality license that they pay us and
those are pretty high numbers right it's
like in the
thousands or ten thousands right and um
you know you before we started to use
stablecoin so nowadays basically
30 or 40 of our customers are actually
paying us with stable coins they're
paying us with usdc or taxes that's
basically
what we expect except and but before
that 50 percent
just so we're clear 50 percent are yeah
five zero wow that's a very big number
okay sorry somewhere between uh forty or
fifty percent i don't know i'm sure
exactly
yeah uh but uh more and more we're
actually pushing more and more of our
customers to pass with stable coins and
we'll get to the point why
right so uh before uh before we
we started accepting stable coins uh we
uh
we were basically accepting either a
wire ach
or stripe right and then at some point
and yeah why are ach
okay they're reasonably cheap but it
takes you
for ach it takes you 24 hours until it
clears into your bank account and for
wire you know like basically wire
international wire
takes three days and occasionally it's
being lost like you know somewhere in
the
mid-atlantic and you never get it and
you know you people need to
to figure out which bank your your
payment is stuck so
it's more inconvenient but it's not like
awfully uh
expensive um when when it came to
but at some point basically we had a
customer that told us that they want to
pass 30 000
over stripe in a credit card and my
sales lady asked us
ask me hey can we process that oh hell
no i'm not paying stripe like you know
ten thousand
sorry one thousand dollars which is like
three percent of the transaction
right and as a commission for getting a
payment
so we tell them to basically send us it
in in usdc
and and it's really convenient because
they're basically sending it over the
firebox network
uh but in reality like you know what i
was supposed to pay
but what i was supposed to pay to strive
for like you know
1 000 commission and hopefully get it
clear
after 48 hours i paid you know we paid i
think
50 cents like back in the days the 8th
price was low so we probably paid like
you know
50 cents on the transaction and it
cleared with like you know five seconds
and basically we sent it to coinbase you
know off ramped it using a
silver getting to into our bank account
it was just magical right and
once that happened we basically told you
know all of our customers we basically
put on the invoice
this is like you know the firebox
network id pass and usdc
and packs and we're trying to push more
and more now
then comes the question about ach and
wire and the thing is that
because it's truly digital you can
actually build automation right so
you can build hooks in terms of getting
those payments and reconciling those
payments you can look at the
the blockchain and you can use device so
we're actually depositing into compound
and
and we you know we we're getting like a
pretty significant interest you know if
i'm trying to basically
put it as a you know put it in deposit
in my uh
in my silicon valley bank account we're
getting i don't know like
a quarter of a percent interest rate
uh when we deposit the usdc clearly you
know
depending depends on the day but it's
it's orders of magnitude higher
so you know overall i think that stable
coins are just this
phenomenal thing and i think that the
traditional players they see it
they also essentially need it regardless
of their
specific initiative right so whether
they're planning to do
bitcoin custody or they're planning to
basically tokenize securities
they need a settlement flag and that
settlement settlement like has to be
digital because digital in a sense that
it has to run on blockchain
because if it's not running on
blockchain it actually reduces all the
beauty of why they're doing it because
they basically
want to do atomic swaps which they call
dvp but basically those are atomic swaps
and that just
reduces the counterparty risk between
those institutions
and it's very very very meaningful for
them
got it and so if we talk a little bit
more about d5 specifically
how do you see either your existing
customers like where is the demand for
the d5 products
um and then how do you think about what
is centralized versus anything
decentralized that either you're
interfacing with or things that
you guys are building yeah so
i mean personally i'm really a big
uh promoter of uh you know defy and you
know i think that this is
definitely the the biggest promise of uh
of crypto
um but i don't think it
i mean it's definitely one of those
areas that are
emerging um funny enough we released our
support to compound the
literally a year ago i think it was like
beginning of february
2020 and no one cared we we had a
we had like a press release i think the
only the only
publication that covered that was the
block and even
on that article you know we had some of
our customers that basically commented
yeah we're not going to use it um
and then like make him and and liquidity
mining uh started and
it basically i think propelled uh
initially i think everybody
thought that it's just like a spec
speculative
activity and once the liquidity mining
will
will try uh it will basically disappear
and you know things will go back to c5
but uh i think the most exciting thing
is that it's here to stay so people
continue using it
and now i think it basically moved the
market to be
much more acceptable and you know people
understand the risk that they also
understand how to use the tools and
maybe the most important thing
is that it really built the on-ramp
into those protocols or at least like
the from our my perspective the
institutional rom
onramp because it forced us and to be
honest like also some of our competitors
to really
devote strategic resources to create
institutional uh browser extension
apis for dfi and now our customers can
basically securely access anything from
uni swap to
curve to to you know compound avi you
know any any of those
protocols and the amount of
interaction that we're seeing over there
is is overwhelming so when we released
our you know initial set of capabilities
around the generic capabilities two
months ago
we thought it was going to be a niche
use case and we'll have you know
five or ten customers that are going to
use it like 90 of our customers
basically want to use it
so that's pretty pretty amazing
absolutely
and so when you think through um the
most surprising thing that's played out
over let's call it the last 12 months so
obviously we've had a public health
crisis we've had
a massive kind of government central
bank intervention
uh most of the uh crypto industry has
exploded in growth
from user standpoint from a uh value
transaction standpoint i'm going to go
on a limb and say firebox has done very
well
uh during the last 12 months but what's
been the most surprising thing to you
as all this has played out
i think that the most surprising thing
was actually
how you know that there are two things
one
is the propagation into mainstream
right i i mean of course it basically
tied
to the health crisis that is tied into
the
uh concerns from inflation but
12 months ago and again we we always
played
in the what we call the crypto native
space so those are like you know our
core customers you know
block fights celsius and genesis and you
know all the
all the folks that you know we we know
and love
and we were also very close or at least
we were trying to work with all the
big banks right um in the big banks it
was always sort of
yeah they were they were interested but
it was
unclear to when they going to do it
or why they're going to do it and what's
going to be the trigger and of course
there was always like you know the
regulatory concern that
that was basically an element that no
one had nothing like there was
yeah you were sort of like at the mercy
of the regulator right when are they
going to approve it
so i think that at the end of the day
the
triangulation of those three things
basically
the um i think the overall um
transformation then the real i think
economic force behind
um you know behind
why bitcoin and why cryptocurrency
important
and then i guess surprisingly basically
the timing with the regulatory clarity
from the lcc
and the sec eventually uh is
what sort of drove almost like the speed
in which those banks have changed from
it's sort of like a niche group
of you know in their innovation
department or a few folks that they have
like a vp of blockchain
to a mainstream conversation where
the literally like you know the number
two or number three in the bank
are driving and this is for them uh the
most important thing you know not only
the banks but also
you know i see it with mastercard and
people and all those
and big players that for me the fact
that it happened
so quickly it's really surprising you
know i would expect that this will be a
really gradual process that will take
maybe two to three years the fact that
it basically happened
nearly in their i guess uh speeds you
know
overnight i wouldn't expect it
yeah and talk a little bit as you kind
of think through
um you know the customer base that
you've built you're serving as
uh kind of this amazing infrastructure
how big is this right and i know that
it's a little sensitive in terms of like
what data points you want to share you
don't want to share but just like
what can you share with folks that they
understand just kind of how much of a
critical piece of infrastructure you
guys should be coming
yeah so we now have about
200 customers uh in our space
uh it's always hard to say how much is
that you know from a percentage
standpoint
but you know it's uh it's decent i guess
and interestingly enough we have a lot
of big
i mean i don't know if the big big guys
but we do have the
mid-big guys uh in the in the space that
are using us
and partnering with us and um
you know just to give some interesting
numbers in the last
30 days um to be honest i didn't check
today because i assume that
things have changed overnight but
in the last 30 days maybe uh 31 days
we we've we've we were our
infrastructure was responsible for about
80 billion dollars of on-chain
settlements
and that sort of represents somewhere
between
you know three to five percent of the
overall tr
on chain transactions so i think it's
already quite decent you know in terms
of uh
what you see as a as a market activity
um i think one of the things that we
continuously think about is how to
make sure that we are not becoming um a
critical risk right for the
for the for the for the industry or for
the for the market and you know we have
quite of interesting uh
approaches over there that we're going
to evaluate in the next
12 months for sure and then when you
think through like the obstacles to the
business as you continue to grow
uh what do you see as the largest
obstacles or challenges is it something
that's internal in terms of scaling
and just building or something that's
external that
you've got to be aware of but might
actually be outside of your control
yeah i mean i think that one of the
interesting you know there are a lot of
challenges to be honest because we are
really scaling quickly at the beginning
of
i mean 12 months ago we were 30 people
in the company and now we have over 90
or
maybe like you know approaching 100
people right so
scanning like threefold in 12 months
during coved
was not an easy task but hopefully we've
managed that well
and also from a customer standpoint
carry making sure that all of our
customers are happy and they're getting
the sla and the services that they need
and
you know we do serve as a really
critical component for them
and that's also a challenge to
to continue and perform but you know
strategically i think
that we are at this point where
the market and the use cases open up
right it's almost that every
scaled company right now can be
everything for
everyone right so yeah i mean you don't
need like specifically fire blocks as an
example you can also even look at
players like coinbase or blockfire that
you can see
how diversified they are right in terms
of the use cases that they are serving
and yeah same applies for us right we
have
use cases that are around trading and we
have use cases around payment that we
use you
have use cases around prime brokerage
and we have use cases around lending
and now you know there is this amazing
use case around treasury management for
for corporations and the their use cases
around um
you know merchant uh merchant sorry
cross-border remittance and one of the
i think like you know strategically for
us the the challenges
is really how to navigate and how to
time
um which one of those pockets we want to
go after and address at every
given moment and because eventually
i believe that you need to have the
right product and you need to you know
have a quality product to serve
a specific niche um so timing it and
putting the the resources is something
that we
you know i see it as one of our
challenges for the next uh
like three or four years yeah and in
terms of
um kind of the macro environment of the
industry
uh talk a little bit about how you see
uh this collision course with uh with
wall street right it's just a world
where they're all going to capitulate
and they have to support digital assets
uh and it'll co-exist alongside the
legacy world do you see it completely
disrupting them and they're eventually
all going to be built
uh and playing on top of like open
decentralized protocols
just when you kind of zoom out from just
fire blocks you think industry
and you kind of meet wall street you
know at some point in the future how
does that play out
yeah i think it's a good question you
know i've
always been sort of uh a strong believer
in
um like very disruptive
innovation right so i think that people
always think that
you know people over sort of
underestimate
how long it will take for the change to
trigger and they always
um overestimate you know how i mean
they don't really able to understand how
quickly that change
when the change actually comes how
quickly it's going to disrupt them
right um and you know traditionally
you've seen it with companies like you
know
ibm and okay like you know blockbusters
and others that basically
it took way longer to something to
happen but when it happened it happened
so quickly that they just couldn't react
so um i think that
overall uh this change is actually going
to happen
you know fairly quickly for them and
i think that some of those institutions
will be able to react and accommodate so
i guess there will be
the microsoft's of the world you know
yes like you know
the cloud is going is it will be a
disruptive for them
and for some period they will lag behind
aws or
amazon but eventually they will be able
to to catch up and they will become as
powerful as them and i think some of
those guys will be the ibm's and they
will basically
you know over time become
will become less and less relevant
because they won't be able to monetize
modernize their infrastructure and by
the way the
the modernization of their
infrastructure is really really
deep because you know just to give like
stupid examples
um if you
to to for their systems to even deal
with the precision that you have with
bitcoin
or ethereum right basically like you
know six digits right
precision right they don't have systems
that know how to do it today right
basically they need to re-platform
everything including
the web interface of the bank um
so as you can imagine you know some of
those guys will not be able to catch up
with uh
with that as well at all yeah
what is the thing that uh you're
spending the most time thinking about as
we move forward right
you uh founded and run one of these
critical pieces of infrastructure
what keeps you up at night right now or
like what are the one or two uh
data points or milestones that you're
looking for from an industry perspective
yeah i think that um there are two
things that are
keeping me up at night one is uh or
maybe like you know three
um the first one is um just
day-to-day operations right that you
know to make sure that
we as i said make sure that we
everything functions properly
right the uh the system is uh
the system is up and running and and all
those uh things work for our customers
and the second is really the strategy of
sort of how to
make sure that we i mean again there is
sort of like the five
years strategy but also there is like
the 12-month strategy of how do we
really
go about um the newer pl the newest
players that are coming in right like
the fintechs of the world the neobanks
that create that they're going
all of those guys are going to move in
the next 12 months and they're going to
provide services so for example
revolut is a customer of ours but it's
also very clear that
all their you know competitors are going
to do something
in the next uh uh 12 months or so and we
need to basically be ready to
to to set an infrastructure for them and
the last piece is actually talent
right so hiring and and scaling and
making sure that we have the best talent
uh there is uh in the company
is also something that you know as a ceo
is very important for me i
i'm like a strong believer and the a
player
brings in a player and like you know b
player brings a c player so
fundamentally the reason why we were
able to execute so quickly
was because we have great people and we
as we scale you know to maintain it
is always something that you need to be
very thoughtful of
absolutely before i finish up i would
ask everyone the same three questions
and then you'll get to ask me one
question to finish up uh the first one
is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
um professionally or personally
either what whatever whatever comes to
mind i think you know personally one of
the best
books that i read is catch 22. and
um i think you know i right after the
period that uh
when i was sort of like you know uh uh
toward the end of my military service
and instead of like you know change my
perception about uh
the world and you know uh i guess the
[Music]
some of the uh you know
things that we the perceptions of that
people have about how the world works
and what like you know what what really
matter and like you know how
i guess uh
you know how we we perceive
things that are absolutely not the real
truth right that was basically
uh and it sort of like you know goes
about in a very sarcastic way
right so that was basically i think one
of the most uh
interesting books that i read it was
like 20 years ago and uh
i think you know professionally probably
a book called four steps to epiphany
which is really
like a bible of how to develop product
and you know
achieve product market fit absolutely
second question
is more personal sleep schedule uh i've
been using the new eight sleep
thermoregulated bed
uh i used to be like a five six hour
sleeper now i basically sleep like on an
ice cube
and uh and get much better sleep and
it's been like life changing for me
uh with the the uh asleep stuff but uh
what what is your sleep schedule and how
has that
uh kind of changed over the years so
i guess like you know before i had kids
i would sleep like you know 12 hours i
really like to sleep
um you know nowadays my five years old
unfortunately like you know comes in the
middle of night and kicks me like you
know for the rest of the night so
uh i wish i i could say that i have like
you know a six hour sleep
as but uh yeah maybe i should like you
know bring a big ice cube and then he
will like you know stay in his bed
last question is more fun aliens are you
a believer or a non-believer
oh that's a good question uh
i think that uh you know like real
aliens like you know green aliens that
come to visit us or like if there are
like you know
uh other forms of uh life uh
whatever you think yeah so i think like
you know b
i definitely i you know i studied
physics so i definitely believe that
like you know b
is definitely a good probability that
there is like a another life form
uh in in in the universe you know like
area 51 conspiracy theories are i guess
like you know
i i you know i think that uh after i
stopped watching um
you know x-files when i was uh you know
16 or 17 years old i
i sort of dropped that conspiracy theory
i i i love that people now have to say
you know are we talking about green men
or not
right when they talk about aliens
because people are getting smarter about
the whole thing
uh what one question do you have for me
to uh to finish up
actually that's a good question so like
aliens what's your view
i i've talked about a million times uh
so i think that they
there's other intelligent life that
exists somewhere in the world but it is
so far away that you and i in our
lifetime won't come in contact with it
which you know kind of kind of calls
into the question does that mean that
they actually exist or not right if we
don't get it
engaged with them then maybe it doesn't
matter yeah but maybe like you know our
grand grand grandchildren we like you
know
have some kind of crazy technology that
will be able to propel them through
wormholes and they will be able to meet
them absolutely
uh how can we find people to find you on
the internet um or where can we send
people to find you on the internet or or
find out more about firefox
yeah sure so uh on our website
firebox.com and
linkedin you know pretty active there uh
michael shalov
awesome michael listen thank you so much
for taking the time to do this i think
people are really gonna enjoy it you've
built some uh
some amazing technology and a great
company and uh i hope that you keep
going and want to do this again in the
future
sounds good thanks